and and a couple things emerge from that
study that I think are really important
for for understanding American education
policy the first is that a very
significant proportion of kids tell us
that they're just going through the
motions when they're in school I mean
that they're not engaged that they're
not trying their hardest that they're
bored and clearly we are not challenging
kids in American schools as much as we
should and you see this if you do
international comparisons we didn't in
this study but if you look at how much
time kids spend on homework for example
the average in our study and this is a
figure that you see in lots of different
studies is about four to five hours a
week for a typical high school students
in Japan it's four to five hours a day
and so you see the difference in
magnitude of how hard we push kids here
in America compared to other other
places the only thing that we found was
that parents and peers have a huge
impact on kids engagement in school
independent of what's going on in the
classroom and so kids who are raised in
households where their parents practice
a better parenting a kind of parenting
that has been called authoritative
parenting where their their firm but
they're warm and where their parents are
involved in their schooling where they
go to school conferences over that those
kids do better in school at the same
time it's not just the home because we
also found that there's significant peer
pressure on kids that makes a difference
and unfortunately more often than not
it's peer pressure to do not as well as
you might so very high proportion of
kids told us that they refrain from
raising their hand in class to answer a
question because they're afraid that
their peers will make fun of them and so
we need to do something to transform the
culture that says it's okay to be smart
you can also be cool in other ways but
it's also okay to be smart now perhaps
the most controversial finding that we
came up with had to do with ethnic
differences in achievement across all of
the schools that we studied Asian
American kids were doing significant
better than white kids and white kids
were doing significantly better than
black and Latino kids and that's
controlling for family income it's
controlling for parental education it's
controlling for other factors that might
be correlated with ethnicity and that
might have played a role in this too
and when we look at why that is we see
several important things the first is
this is a great question that one of my
collaborators said we have to put this
on a questionnaire and the question was
what's the lowest grade you could get
without your parents getting angry all
right so the Asian kids
it's an a-minus right for the white kids
you know it's more like a B and for the
black and Latino kids it's somewhere you
know around a b-minus or c-plus so
clearly there are different expectations
in these households the second thing is
that when we ask kids about the
importance of schooling we see really
different patterns and how kids from
different ethnic groups answer the
question
Asian kids tell us that they are sure
that if they do poorly in school
something bad will happen to them they
won't get a good job unless all right
black and to a certain extent Latino
kids don't have that belief so it every
all ethnic groups share the belief that
doing well in school has a payoff
it's how they think about doing poorly
in school that makes a difference and
the Asian kids do well in part because
they're really afraid of what the
consequences of not doing well are and I
think that comes back to the standards
that their parents have set for them at
home
I don't know I mean about about
it's changed attitudes it certainly
hasn't done anything to kids achievement
which has stayed pretty flat so if you
look at the at these tests that are
given by the federal government year
after year after year I mean there's a
little bit of fluctuation from year to
year there's been a little improvement
and I think 8th grade math something
like that but but across the board I
think anybody looking at the data
objectively would say that none of the
things that we've tried to do in the
last 30 years has made a difference
achievement is lower now than it was in
the 1970s and that's what that's partly
what prompted us to do this study right
because we're spent we spend all this
money on school reform and we're
constantly having debates about how we
train teachers what we pay teachers how
much money we give schools whether we
should have big schools or small schools
people try to do all these experiments
where they change these things and it
doesn't make a difference really doesn't
make a difference I'm not saying that
teachers shouldn't be well paid of
course they should be well-paid but that
alone is not going to raise achievement
among American students to schools need
resources of course they need resources
but lots of research shows that there is
a very small relationship between the
resources that a school gets and the
output that produces in kids and and I
think and I think if you look at
projects like the the Harlem Children's
Zone where they have they have attacked
this problem as a community problem and
not as a problem that's just located in
the classroom and they're seeing
terrific results there so our point in
this book is that you really need to
think about the whole context in which
kids grow up and not just what takes
place inside the classroom
well you know the fact that
underprivileged kids do so poorly in
school is a huge huge problem for
society but with tremendous implications
for our economic future and and the gap
between the rich and poor has grown
considerably in that a trickles down to
achieve and it's not just in terms of a
family income the way that we finance
schools I think is misguided and and
disadvantages kids from poor
neighborhoods so certainly unhinging
school financing from property taxes
which would allow us to redistribute tax
income in a way that would be more
equitable would certainly be something
that's that's important a second thing
is this issue of standards we just don't
hold a kids in poor neighborhoods to the
same academic standards that we hold
kids and wealthy neighborhoods to and so
when kids in poor neighborhoods get
promoted from grade to grade or graduate
from school it's often a sham I mean
often their diplomas are meaningless I
mean there are kids with high school
diplomas in this country who can read no
better than at a 5th grade level and so
we have dismissed that population of
young people as being not important
enough to really care about we also need
to to do a better job at engaging their
families in in their schooling a lot of
their parents of course had their own
problems in school and so they are more
reluctant they're more uncomfortable
showing up in school because it was a it
was an uncomfortable place for them when
they were kids so we need to think of
better ways of getting parents involved
in their kids education
well I think that we we can make schools
more challenging I mean for starters so
that kids are pushed harder and come out
with with better skills and more
knowledge than they are right now I'm
somebody who favors national exams and
having national standards I believe I
may be wrong off by one country or so
but I believe every industrialized
country in the world except the United
States has national standards for kids
achievement so I think allowing
education to be kind of a local issue is
part of the problem because it allows
districts to set their own standards
we've moved away from that a little bit
but there's been a huge rebellion
against that and people have spoken out
against performance-based evaluations of
kids I think it's a good thing to do you
know the major objection to it is that
it forces teachers to teach to the test
and that they're not doing things in
classroom that are that are creative or
that promote critical thinking well if
that's the case we need to design better
tests I mean there's no problem with
teaching to the test that the test is
measuring something that you want kids
to to achieve so I think there are a
number of things that we could do to
improve academic achievement among
American kids